season five brings big changes to
lucifer's world with one of the most
intriguing occurring after lucy and
chloe take their relationship to the
next level
and discover his powers have
dramatically changed yipikai movie
lovers i'm jan and in this video i'll be
revealing the hidden secret from season
one that explains why lucifer and
chloe's powers transformed in season
five
spoilers ahead so take care if you're
not caught up there are some strange
goings-on with lucifer's mojo in season
five
the crucial moment being the morning
after lucy and chloe finally sleep
together when lucifer suddenly discovers
that chloe has acquired one of his
superpowers and can mojo him what do you
truly desire
on top of that later that day lucifer
finds that he seems to have lost his own
mojo
niels tell me what do you truly
desire is this the way you people solve
crimes but in the final episode
after he becomes invulnerable again
around chloe he discovers his mojo's
returned
if i still have my mojo i'd just ask
what is it you desire
i want to be a dancer for a full
understanding of what's going on here we
need to go back to a discussion lucifer
had with linda in the first season when
he was trying to understand why chloe
was the only person he knew who was
immune to him
was she able to refuse my charms it's
not that you're afraid that you don't
have power over chloe it's that you're
afraid that she has power over you but
people
don't have power over us we give it to
them you have to take your power back
we can see how this applies in season
five when lucifer is repeatedly annoyed
that chloe has seemingly taken his power
away
what do you desire i want my motor back
which is why when lucifer's mojo returns
in the eighth episode it's likely
because he subconsciously took back his
power and stopped feeling so insecure
as co-showrunner joe henderson said in
an interview with variety
for season five they wanted to find a
way to physicalize lucifer's
insecurities and the mojo became an
excellent opportunity to do that
another good example of lucifer's
insecurity or anxiety about this issue
is how he went running to dr linda for
an impromptu therapy session
straight after discovering that chloe
could mojo him henderson's comments also
tie in with the running theme in the
series that angels can self-actualize
which was particularly evident in season
four when lucifer took on a more
monstrous appearance and grew backwings
because of his self-loathing
indeed lucy's white feather angel wings
returned as soon as he overcame those
feelings and began to accept himself for
who he
is and realized that chloe did too by
the way
ironically it was during that same
conversation with linda in season one
that i mentioned earlier that lucifer
came to the conclusion he could solve
the problem of his powers not working on
chloe by sleeping with her
so you understand yes i need to have sex
with her
ah that's not what i said no no you're a
genius little did he know that when this
eventually happened
the result would be the exact opposite
the temporary loss of his mojo
the next big change in lucy's powers
comes in the part one finale when he
discovers he's now invulnerable
even when he's physically near to chloe
the moment occurs just
after dan shoots lucifer and chloe who
was in the same room at the time is
distraught and assumes the worst may
have happened to him but then he gets up
completely unharmed and
delighted with the new state of affairs
shoots himself again
invulnerable because he's an angel
lucifer normally can't be killed or hurt
by ordinary mortal weapons
however from the fourth episode of
season one onwards the series
established that whenever chloe was
nearby
he could be injured and he's even died
twice in the show so far
although those deaths have always been
temporary so how did lucifer regain his
invulnerability around chloe
well for the answer let's go back to the
moment just before dan arrived to shoot
lucifer
chloe had just suggested to lucy that
because she could mojo him it meant for
the first time that he was
opening up to her however noticed
lucifer's reaction as he begins to
understand the implications of that
i think i may have dropped my guard and
as chloe goes off to freshen up her
realization dawns upon lucifer about
something she told him previously
regarding one of a menadiel's theories
he thinks that you choose to be
vulnerable around me i think he might be
right
and dr linda pointed out to chloe
earlier in season five that lucifer is
unfathomably
narcissistic utterly terrified of
intimacy and sabotages everything good
that ever happens to him so in that
short time between chloe walking off and
dan arriving
it seems that lucifer made a
subconscious decision to be invulnerable
again around chloe
and lucifer's return to invulnerability
around chloe also answers why he wasn't
injured in the slightest in the show's
pilot episode when he was shot at
point-blank range while very close to
chloe
this season 5 development seems to
confirm the theory that because lucifer
hadn't yet developed a full emotional
connection to the detective or
insecurities in that first episode he
was still
invulnerable around her as for chloe she
fears this change means luther doesn't
love her any longer
now you're invulnerable all the time
doesn't that mean that you're
no longer choosing to be vulnerable with
me now michael has obviously amplified
this fearing chloe but even though
lucifer is now invulnerable again think
of me as your human shield
or devil shield it's evident that he
still has feelings for her when he goes
to say
chloe lucifer using chloe's real name
rather than detective
is an important call back to that major
moment in the season 4 finale when he
confessed his love for
her my first love was never eve was you
chloe so the real answer as to what's
going on here
maybe that lucifer has decided emotional
vulnerability with chloe
doesn't have to lead to physical
vulnerability around her
in other words he's got his former
insecurities in check
as a menadil told chloe you're the only
mortal who sees
him for who he truly is because she's
immune to lucifer's mojo
she sees him for who he truly is rather
than reflecting onto him her own desires
and wishes
and that allows lucifer to see the good
in himself in other words that he's more
than just a cipher for people's desires
and a punisher of their sins
and interestingly enough some advice dr
linda gave lucy in the first season
turned out to be pretty pertinent to all
this
sometimes we need to lose something
before we can understand
its value when angels fall they also
rise all you have to do is embrace
all that you are now what about chloe's
new mojo powers in season five
well so far it seems like they only work
on lucifer
neither she nor lucy were able to mojo
the opera singer niels
and chloe believes her power only
appeared to work on mario the vocal
coach because he was a hot tub high
school fan and he simply responded to
her because he was starstruck
what do you desire to tell you anything
you want to know
curiously there was also an incident in
season 4 where it seems like chloe might
have already acquired lucifer's mojo
why did you desire the files in the
drive
because i didn't want anyone to know
what i had done however it's likely that
chloe was piggybacking off lucy's mojo
which was going wild at the time given
that all the guests at lux were coming
up to tell him their desires without him
even asking them
and that moment was possibly also some
foreshadowing for what the writers had
planned for chloe in season five
intriguingly after learning she was a
gift from god chloe hoped it meant she
had some powers herself
so do you have any powers or anything
cool
i don't know laser beam hands something
so in the future
could she acquire some more of lucifer's
superpowers for example if she became
immortal like him this would resolve the
problem that as a human she's destined
to die
while lucifer will live forever though
it would leave her with the problem of
daughter trixie still being mortal
and i talk more about that and other
predictions for the show's final seasons
in my theories video
click here for that or follow the link
in the video description
if you enjoyed this video then a thumbs
up is hugely appreciated
tap left for my full lucifer playlist
with videos on all the easter eggs you
missed in season 5
my part 1 ending video with an
explanation of what to expect from god
in part 2
and cool secrets about the making of the
show or tap right for something else
you're sure to like
thanks for watching and see you next
time yippee guy movie lovers